hallo mein name ist luca meine damen und
herren mein absoluter lieblingssender t
die haben eine neue serie am start und
diese serie trägt den namen temptation
highland bei der serie geht es darum
dass einige pärchen auf eine insel
fahren und auf dieser insel warten
verschiedene model männer und frauen und
die leute die auf diese insel fahren
also diese pärchen testen quasi ihre
beziehung und gucken wer am längsten
aushalten kann ohne fremdzugehen ich mal
darüber nachdenkt ist es echt hart
gestört auf jeden fall schauen wir uns
die heute die erste folge an und ich
würde sagen ich klicke einfach weil
direkt auf playstation island die insel
der versuchung
[Musik]
ich frag mich einfach wie rtl jedes mal
ein neues konzept überlegt hier aber
wollen die liebe testen
[Musik]
gerade kinder liebe geflüstert es hat da
nicht mal angefangen die brecht schon
drehen aber dafür trennen sie sich für
zwei wochen
aha okay ich dachte die sind zusammen
unterwegs aber anscheinend rennen die
sich dann sogar für zwei wochen
heiße verführer und sexy verführerinnen
[Musik]
ihnen die zwar gerade brüste musste ich
gerade dann zensieren aber es läuft doch
im fernsehen alter wie kanäle um 20.15
der brüste direkt im intro zeigen nur am
lagerfeuer
[Musik]
dass ihre partner in der anderen villa
erleben
[Musik]
das ist ja irre
will ein mann mehr da würde ich jemanden
banane veranstaltet ich bin eher so ein
typ der sehr viel sex der wir die
holzköpfe aus dem wald direkt dahin
geflogen worden
alter sorry da habe ich mir bei dem
schild mehr mühe gegeben alter als die
bei ihrem ganzen leben wahrscheinlich
bisher dafür dass ich in den letzten
videos überhaupt immer den inhalt des
videos auf dieses schild geschrieben
habe würde ich sagen lass dir schonmal
direkten like bei diesem video hier also
überhaupt nichts gegen die ich
persönlich kenne ich habe so wie du
aussiehst echt natürliche schönheit
herzlich willkommen auf temptation die
paare sondern angekommen ist jana und
fabians aber da als model und als
tennistrainer auch dass diese szene
kommen
das war auch klar weshalb wir
überspringen die vorstellung von den
pannen die sind ja eh gegen die alle ein
bisschen klemp level agieren
beziehungsweise können uns ein paar auf
einmal kurz auf der website hier von rtl
anschauen
wir haben einmal christina dimitriou und
salvatore fast hallo alle sind die zwei
hier ach das war unsere natürliche
schönheit h nummer zwei die sich auf die
insel traut sind lena die viola und
robin liebling ich glaube die beiden da
die die könnten schaffen da
durchzukommen leyen dass ich sage die
könnten es schaffen dadurch zu kommen
müssen einfach nur zwei wochen nicht mit
wem anders schlafen was müssen sich
aliens denken wenn sie plötzlich auf dem
mars irgendwie tv empfang haben
unterläuft temptation eiland im
fernsehen also ich glaube die werden
unseren planeten direkt in die luft
jagen das dritte paar dass dabei ist
besteht aus lisa sauer und jannis scotty
mehr hoffe ich dass lisa nicht sauer
wird weil die sehen ein bisschen aus wie
mutter und sohn und das vierte und
letzte pärchen das seine
testet auf der temptation insel besteht
aus ca ruby und fabian nickel das sind
die beiden hier okay sagt er selber dass
er sehr glücklich ist mit mir und ich
weiß dass er das tun als kaputt machen
ja das werden wir dann sehen ist tina
und salvador ist es ja wirklich ein
großes thema was eifersucht und
vertrauen angeht dass tina vertraust du
selber tore sind gerade erst angekommen
und sie sagt schon dass sie mich
vertraut hier soll ändert ähnlich wie
heißt noch mal sybille und klaus herzer
mal das eine oder andere auch mal
schauen gemacht deswegen ist für mich
auf jeden fall eine riesengroße
herausforderung
klaus du bist schon mehrmals
fremdgegangen also ich meine fremdgehen
ist das schlimmste was zu einer
beziehung an tun kannst und ich finde
wenn man ein mädchen oder eine frau hier
in dem fall die sie bisher anscheinend
schon ein bisschen älter fremdgehen ist
somit das schlimmste was in einer
beziehung vorgehen kann und sie sagt
hier schon ja gut er klaus erich und
auch fremd gegangen hatte ja schon drauf
fremdgegangen dachte ich wir fahren mal
noch mal hierhin dann kann er noch öfter
fremdgehen cdm sda
wenn ich mir so unsicher war und
deswegen habe ich auch keinen zugang
mehr auf sein profil
mal ganz kurz die sibylle den klaus
gesorgt
weil sie kein vertrauen hatte
kein zugriff mehr auf sein profil an
alle zuschauer hier die in einer
beziehung sind hat euer partner zugriff
auf euer instagram profil youtube
account whatsapp also juli bei mir nicht
aber die sie billig da wohl ein bisschen
anders obwohl ich mich ehrlich gesagt
frage bei der überhaupt irgendwas tickt
ach ne werbung ja komm gib mir geld das
gefühl dass etwas großes auf uns wartet
ja meine ängste sind anderes kann doch
nicht passieren und mein gott alter die
gehirnzellen von den beiden geht noch
ins negative es ist sehr lange nicht
verboten oder so hat der klaus hat
gesagt dass fremdgehen ja nicht verboten
ist
das ist wirklich das pärchen da wird es
glaube ich am meisten abgeben ganz kurze
anmerkungen geben ich habe ja eigentlich
gesagt dass wir die pärchen vorstellung
überspringen allerdings habe ich mir
dann gedacht dass wir auf jeden fall auf
diese 25 nasen hier reagieren müssen
und jetzt geht weiter okay das ist jetzt
das letzte mal dass die zusammen sind
jetzt werden die zusammen auseinander
hatten die verschiedenen häuser gefallen
anfassen ist ab jetzt nicht mehr erlaubt
und es wird schnell ernst hier kommen
ihre neuen mitbewohner ganz
die werden dich einzelnen die wellen
gepackt sondern die paare sitzen sich
jetzt gegenüber mit ihnen die 20 meter
abstand und jetzt kommen die mitbewohner
und mitbewohnerinnen jetzt bin ich aber
mal gespannt auf die reaktion also die
frauen sind heiß das sind jetzt auch die
frauen mit
ich glaube ich gesagt ich gebe dem klaus
zehn minuten bei den frauen ist auf
jeden fall konkurrenz potenzial darin
werden alle genauer kennenlernen dürfen
aber ihr dürft euch jetzt schon mal
jeder eine frau aus
[Musik]
also
was das ist mal ganz kurz an die frauen
die dort gesagt haben hey ich will mit
dem fashion island als sexy
verführerisches model mitmachen
was haltet ihr denn von euch
irgendjemand darf sich aussuchen und ihr
werdet einfach als objekt abgestempelt
von wegen hey du gehst zu dem letztlich
für dich entschieden alter in was für
einem jahr leben wir zudem zerstören
diese singles halt auch einfach noch
beziehungen also glückwunsch an euch ihr
seid moralisch gesehen
also es kann sein dass er sie auch gut
findet aber sorry aber sie ist er viel
viel viel viel hübscher so wie ich das
jetzt mal objektiv
ich finde sie auf jeden fall viel viel
hübscher als sie für die er sich
entschieden hat denke dass ich mit ihr
spaß haben werden kann und ich denke
dass ich mit ihr spaß haben werden kann
die zweite von links im weißen kleid das
ist eine freundin und das ist die für
der sich entschieden hat alter diesen
genau gleich aussieht sowie ein
engelchen aus aber ich kann auch ganz
anders alles klar
[Musik]
ganz rechts
also
vielleicht seien nicht mein geschmack
aber city sieht aus wie 40 oder so ich
bin anastasia und bin 30 jahre als einer
von euch dass ich jetzt eine blumenkette
nehmen und dem mann um den hals hängen
den ihr am besten im moment findet also
das ist ja wirklich in dem konzept drin
noch mal zehn konzepte irgendwie also
hut ab rtl sache hat jetzt allerdings
nur einen haken eure frauen müssen sich
eine single lady aufpicken die geblockt
wird und wieder ein konzept in konzepten
kurzem im konzept eben konzept im
konzept
im kurzen anastasia okay klaus ey durch
mir echt leid jetzt fabian wir fangen
wieder mit dir an der mitte eine
blumenkette und hängen sie der frau um
mit der du dein erstes date alleine
verbringen möchte ist egal dass wieder
sonne konzett scheiße mann ich will
einfach jetzt mal diese männer models
sehen aber ok auf männer rein kann ich
ehrlich gesagt nichts zu sagen vorstellt
mich natürlich sehr gefreut dass ich
jetzt zwei viererketten bekommen habe
was
also dass sie nur eine bekommen hat er
ja schon vorhersagen können nico wie so
ein straßenschild aber dass sich die
meisten bekommen hätte ich niemals
gedacht
ich dachte safe sie kriegt fünf oder
sechs sibylle man hat gesehen ich habe
leider nur eine kette bekommen dann
siehst du ja auch so haben die interesse
finde dich attraktiv aber das stört
nicht gar nicht weil ich weiss ja auch
so dass ich ganz gut bei den männern ein
[Musik]
kapitel kapitel 2 wie bereits gesagt ist
die erste folge von temptation island
gestern erst rausgekommen von habe ich
mir direkt gedacht komm ich reagiere
direkt auf die erste folge hier und
dachte wie hey wieso geht die erste
folge nur 23 minuten ist natürlich wenn
die nur so kurz geht dann reagiert da
dem schneider auf die erste folge ist in
vier kapitel unterteilt a 24 minuten
also die komplette erste folge
temptation island gehen 100 minuten und
ich kann nicht in einem ganzen video auf
100 minuten videomaterial von rtl
reagieren
ich bin jetzt schon bei fast einer
stunde reaction teil mir gerade von
daher würde ich die heutige folge an der
stelle jetzt auch beenden werde ich
meine reaktion hierauf diese neue rtl
serie namens temptation einen gefallen
hat und ihr wollt dass ich davon noch
einen zweiten teil hat eine zweite
reaktion auf eventuelle folge 2 oder auf
den rest von folge eins an was einen
daumen hoch bei diesem video hier daran
schreibt mir und in die kommentare von
wem ihr denkt von allen männern und
frauen wer wird als erstes fremdgehen
und jetzt kommt das auto
[Musik]